ตัวแก้ eigen แบบควอนตัมเชิงแปรผัน หรือ VQE เป็นหนึ่งในอัลกอริทึมไฮบริดควอนตัม-คลาสสิกที่เก่าแก่ที่สุด และมัน
น่าสนใจด้วยเหตุผลหลายอย่าง อย่างแรก อย่างที่เราจะเห็นในวิดีโอนี้ มันเป็นแนวทางที่มีแนวโน้มดีสำหรับปัญหาบางประเภท อย่างที่สอง มันสำคัญ
ในเชิงประวัติศาสตร์และปูทางสำหรับอัลกอริทึมที่พัฒนาขึ้นหลายตัว เช่น adapt VQE
และสุดท้าย VQE ค่อนข้างง่าย เข้าใจได้ไม่ยากว่าคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมและคลาสสิกทำอะไรในอัลกอริทึมนี้
และมันทำงานร่วมกันอย่างไร มีสี่องค์ประกอบหลักในการคำนวณ VQE
อย่างแรกมี operator มักเป็น Hamiltonian ซึ่งเราเรียกว่า H ที่อธิบายคุณสมบัติของระบบที่
ต้องการ optimize อีกวิธีพูดก็คือคุณกำลังหา eigen vector ของ operator นี้ที่
สอดคล้องกับ eigen value ต่ำสุด เรามักเรียก eigen vector นั้นว่า ground state
ต่อมามี ansatz ซึ่งแปลว่าแนวทาง นี่คือ quantum circuit ที่เตรียม quantum state ที่ประมาณ
eigen vector ที่กำลังหาอยู่ จริงๆ ansatz คือกลุ่มของ quantum circuit เพราะ gate บางตัวใน
ansatz ถูก parameterize นั่นคือมันรับ parameter ที่เราเปลี่ยนแปลงได้ กลุ่มของ quantum circuit นี้
สามารถเตรียมกลุ่มของ quantum state ที่ประมาณ ground state ได้
ต่อมาต้องมี estimator ซึ่งเป็นวิธีประมาณ expectation value ของ operator H สำหรับ quantum state เชิงแปรผัน
ปัจจุบัน บางครั้งสิ่งที่เราสนใจจริงๆ ก็แค่ expectation value นี้เอง ซึ่งเรา
เรียกว่า cost function บางครั้งเราสนใจฟังก์ชันที่ซับซ้อนกว่าที่ยังสามารถเขียนได้โดยเริ่มจาก
expectation value หนึ่งตัวขึ้นไป
สุดท้ายต้องมี classical optimizer ซึ่งเป็นอัลกอริทึมที่ปรับ parameter เพื่อลด cost function นี้ให้ต่ำที่สุด
มาสรุปปัญหาที่ต้องการแก้และแนวทางทั่วไปก่อนพูดถึงบทบาทของควอนตัม เรา
สามารถเขียนปัญหา optimization หลายอย่างที่สำคัญต่อวิทยาศาสตร์และอุตสาหกรรมเป็นปัญหาค่าเมทริกซ์ได้ โดยทั่วไปคุณ
ต้องการ eigen value ต่ำสุดของเมทริกซ์และ eigen vector ที่สอดคล้องกัน เมทริกซ์ H อาจเป็น
Hamiltonian ที่อธิบายพลังงานของระบบทางกายภาพ และ eigen value ต่ำสุดจะเป็น ground state energy
E0 และ eigen vector จะเป็น quantum ground state ที่สอดคล้องกัน มักแสดงด้วย psi sub0
หรือเมทริกซ์อาจอธิบาย cost function ที่ซับซ้อนที่เกี่ยวข้องกับปัญหา combinatorial optimization
เช่นในด้านโลจิสติกส์ และ eigen state s subopt จะเป็นคำตอบที่ดีที่สุดของ
ปัญหา เช่น binary string ที่ระบุการตัดในกราฟของเครือข่ายการกระจายสินค้า ในทางปฏิบัติ
มักได้ยินคำว่า Hamiltonian ใช้สำหรับเมทริกซ์ทั้งหมดที่สนใจ แม้แต่นอกวิทยาศาสตร์กายภาพ สมมุติว่า
เราสนใจเมทริกซ์ที่มี n แถวและ n คอลัมน์ ปัญหาแบบนี้แก้ได้เร็วและแม่นยำโดยใช้
classical solver สำหรับ n ถึงสองสามร้อยหรือพัน โดยไม่มีข้อสมมติเกี่ยวกับเมทริกซ์ สำหรับเมทริกซ์ sparse
ที่มีส่วนใหญ่เป็นศูนย์ n อาจมากถึงพันล้านแม้บน laptop
แต่สำหรับปัญหาที่ใหญ่มากเกินกว่าตัวเลขพวกนี้ มักต้องใช้วิธีประมาณหรือ heuristic
ยิ่งเมทริกซ์ใหญ่และ sparse น้อยลงเท่าไร ปัญหายิ่งยาก และต้องใช้เทคนิคชาญฉลาดมากขึ้น สมมุติว่าเมทริกซ์ของคุณ
ใหญ่มากจนการ diagonalize แบบตรงไม่ใช่ตัวเลือก สมมุติว่าคุณรู้พอเกี่ยวกับปัญหาจนสามารถ
เดาโครงสร้างโดยรวมของ target state ได้ และต้องการสำรวจ state ที่คล้ายกับการเดาเริ่มต้น
เพื่อดูว่า cost หรือพลังงานลดลงได้อีกไหม นี่คือแนวทางเชิงแปรผัน และเป็นวิธีหนึ่งที่
ใช้เมื่อ exact diagonalization ไม่ใช่ตัวเลือกบนคอมพิวเตอร์คลาสสิก วิธีนี้ทำงานดังนี้
อย่างแรก สร้าง guess state ด้วย parameter theta ที่จะเปลี่ยนแปลง
แม้ว่า initial guess อาจสุ่มได้ แต่ไม่แนะนำ ต้องใช้ความรู้เกี่ยวกับปัญหา
เพื่อปรับการเดาให้เหมาะสมที่สุดเท่าที่ทำได้
อย่างที่สอง คำนวณ expectation value ของ operator เมื่อระบบอยู่ใน state นั้น
อย่างที่สาม เปลี่ยน parameter เชิงแปรผัน แล้วทำซ้ำ
อย่างที่สี่ ใช้ข้อมูลสะสมเกี่ยวกับ landscape ของ state ที่เป็นไปได้ใน variational subspace ของคุณเพื่อการเดาที่
ดีขึ้นเรื่อยๆ และเข้าใกล้ target state
variational principle รับประกันว่า variational state ของเราไม่สามารถให้ eigen value ต่ำกว่า
target ground state ได้ ดังนั้น ยิ่ง expectation value ต่ำ ก็ยิ่งประมาณ ground state ได้ดีขึ้น มา
พูดถึงความยากของแต่ละขั้นตอนในแนวทางนี้
การตั้งหรืออัปเดต parameter นั้นง่ายในเชิงคำนวณ ความยากอยู่ที่การเลือก parameter เริ่มต้น
ที่มีความหมายทางกายภาพ การใช้ข้อมูลสะสมจากการวนซ้ำก่อนหน้าเพื่ออัปเดต parameter ในลักษณะที่
เข้าใกล้ ground state นั้นไม่ง่าย แต่มี classical optimization อัลกอริทึมที่ทำสิ่งนี้ได้
ค่อนข้างมีประสิทธิภาพ classical optimization นี้แพงเพราะอาจต้องการการวนซ้ำจำนวนมาก
ในกรณีที่แย่ที่สุด จำนวนรอบอาจ scale แบบ exponential ตาม n
ขั้นตอนเดี่ยวที่แพงที่สุดในเชิงคำนวณเกือบแน่นอนคือ expectation value ของเมทริกซ์โดยใช้
state ที่กำหนด เมทริกซ์ขนาด n คูณ n ต้องทำงานกับเวกเตอร์ที่มี n ส่วนประกอบ ซึ่งสอดคล้องกับการคูณ n กำลัง 2
ในกรณีที่แย่ที่สุด ต้องทำสิ่งนี้ในทุกรอบของ parameter สำหรับเมทริกซ์ขนาดใหญ่มากๆ
มีต้นทุนการคำนวณสูง ตอนนี้ลองจินตนาการว่าส่งส่วนนี้ของ
การคำนวณให้คอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัม แทนที่จะคำนวณ expectation value นี้ คุณประมาณมันโดยเตรียม
state s ของ theta บนคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมโดยใช้ variational ansatz แล้วทำการวัด
มาแยกแยะนิดหน่อย H โดยทั่วไปไม่ง่ายที่จะวัด ตัวอย่างเช่น มันอาจประกอบด้วย
Pauli x y และ z operator ที่ไม่ commute หลายตัว
แต่ H สามารถเขียนเป็น linear combination ของพจน์ H sub alpha แต่ละพจน์ที่วัดได้ง่าย ตัวอย่างเช่น
Pauli operator หรือกลุ่มของ Pauli operator ที่ commute แบบ bitwise
expectation value ของ H สำหรับ state S คือผลรวมถ่วงน้ำหนักของ expectation value ของพจน์ H alpha ส่วนประกอบ
นิพจน์นี้ใช้ได้กับทุก state s แต่เราจะใช้มันกับ variational state s ของ theta โดยเฉพาะ
แต่ละพจน์ h alpha สามารถวัดได้ m ครั้ง ได้ตัวอย่างการวัด s sub alpha j โดย j วิ่งจาก
1 ถึง m และคืนค่า expectation value และ standard deviation เราสามารถรวม
พจน์เหล่านี้และส่งต่อ error ผ่านการรวม
วิธีนี้ไม่ต้องการการคูณขนาดใหญ่หรือกระบวนการใดๆ ที่ scale เหมือน n กำลัง 2 แต่กลับ
ต้องการการวัดหลายครั้งบนคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัม ถ้าไม่ต้องการมากเกินไป แนวทางนี้อาจ
มีประสิทธิภาพ นั่นคือส่วนควอนตัมของ VQE แต่มาพูดถึงเหตุผลที่มันอาจไม่มีประสิทธิภาพ เหตุผลหนึ่ง
สำหรับการวัดมากๆ คือการลด statistical uncertainty ในการประมาณสำหรับความแม่นยำสูงมากๆ
การคำนวณ เหตุผลอีกอย่างคือจำนวน Pauli string ที่ต้องการเพื่อครอบคลุมเมทริกซ์ทั้งหมด เพราะเมทริกซ์ Pauli บวก
identity ครอบคลุม space ของ operator ทั้งหมดในมิติที่กำหนด เราจึงรับประกันได้
ว่าสามารถเขียนเมทริกซ์ที่สนใจเป็นผลรวมถ่วงน้ำหนักของ Pauli operator ตามที่ทำก่อนหน้านี้ ตรงนี้ C alpha คือ
ค่าตัวเลขและ H alpha คือ string ของ Pauli operator ที่ทำงานกับ qubit ทั้งหมดที่อธิบายระบบของคุณ
H alpha จะมีรูปแบบแบบนี้โดย Pauli operator ตัวที่ n จากขวาทำงานกับ qubit ตัวที่ n ดังนั้นเรา
สามารถวัด operator ของเราโดยวัด Pauli operator หลายชุด แต่เราไม่สามารถวัด Pauli operator เหล่านั้น
พร้อมกันทั้งหมดได้ Pauli operator ที่ไม่ใช่ identity ไม่ commute กันถ้ามัน
เกี่ยวข้องกับ qubit เดียวกัน ตัวอย่างเช่น เราวัด I Z IIZ และ ZZ
XZ พร้อมกันได้ เพราะเราวัด I และ Z พร้อมกันได้สำหรับ qubit ตัวที่สาม
และเรารู้ I และ X พร้อมกันได้สำหรับ qubit ตัวแรก แต่เรา
ไม่สามารถวัด Z ทั้งหมดกับ ZZ ZX พร้อมกันได้ เพราะ Z และ X ไม่
commute และทั้งคู่ทำงานกับ qubit ตัวที่ศูนย์
ดังนั้นเราแยกเมทริกซ์ H เป็นผลรวมของ Pauli ที่ทำงานกับ qubit ต่างกัน
องค์ประกอบบางส่วนของผลรวมนั้นวัดได้พร้อมกันทีเดียว เราเรียกนี้ว่ากลุ่มของ Pauli ที่ commute ขึ้นอยู่กับ
จำนวน term ที่ไม่ commute เราอาจต้องการกลุ่มมาก เรียกจำนวนกลุ่มของ Pauli ที่ commute ว่า
t
ถ้า ngcp เล็ก วิธีนี้อาจได้ผลดี
ถ้า h มีล้านกลุ่ม มันจะไม่มีประโยชน์ คุณบันทึก expectation value หรือ cost function
สำหรับชุด parameter theta ที่ใช้ใน state แล้วอัปเดต parameter ตามเวลา คุณอาจใช้
expectation value หรือค่า cost function ที่ประมาณมาเพื่อประมาณ gradient ของ cost function ใน
subspace ของ state ที่สุ่มตัวอย่างจาก ansatz ของคุณ
มีทั้ง classical optimizer แบบใช้ gradient และไม่ใช้ gradient ทั้งคู่มีปัญหา trainability อาจเกิดขึ้นเช่น
local minima หลายจุดและพื้นที่ขนาดใหญ่ของ parameter space ที่มี gradient ใกล้ศูนย์ เรียกว่า barren plateau
แล้ว VQE จะแก้ปัญหาที่ยากที่สุดของคุณได้ไหม ไม่ได้ แต่การเก่งกว่าในทุกการคำนวณก็ไม่ใช่จุดประสงค์ เรา
เปลี่ยนสิ่งที่กำหนด computational cost ดูที่สิ่งที่เราแลกเปลี่ยน เราเปลี่ยนจากกระบวนการ
ที่ความซับซ้อนขึ้นอยู่กับมิติของเมทริกซ์เท่านั้น ไปเป็นอันที่ขึ้นอยู่กับความแม่นยำที่ต้องการและจำนวน
Pauli operator ที่ไม่ commute ที่ประกอบเป็นเมทริกซ์ ส่วนสุดท้ายไม่มีอะไรเทียบในคอมพิวเตอร์คลาสสิก
จากการ dependency ใหม่เหล่านี้ สำหรับเมทริกซ์ sparse หรือเมทริกซ์ที่มี Pauli string ที่ไม่ commute น้อย กระบวนการนี้
อาจมีประโยชน์ กรณีนี้เกิดขึ้นกับระบบสปินที่มีปฏิสัมพันธ์ ตัวอย่างเช่น สำหรับเมทริกซ์ dense มันอาจ
มีประโยชน์น้อยกว่า เรารู้ว่าตัวอย่างเช่น ระบบเคมีมักมี Hamiltonian ที่เกี่ยวข้องกับหลักร้อย หลักพัน หรือแม้แต่
ล้าน Pauli string มีงานวิจัยน่าสนใจที่ทำเพื่อลดจำนวน term นี้ แต่
ระบบเคมีอาจเหมาะกับอัลกอริทึมอื่นๆ ที่เราจะพูดถึงในคอร์สนี้มากกว่า
การใช้ VQE อย่างมีประสิทธิภาพยังต้องการให้เรารู้คุณสมบัติของ target state และสามารถเลือก initial state
ที่มีความหมายทางกายภาพที่ดีรวมถึง ansatz ที่ดีที่มี variational parameter ค่อนข้างน้อย นี่อาจ
ท้าทายพอสมควร VQE แสดงให้เห็นว่าจุดแข็งของคอมพิวเตอร์คลาสสิกและควอนตัมสามารถรวมกันได้
โดยไม่เพิ่มวิธีการล่าสุด VQE ไม่ได้ช่วยแก้ปัญหาที่ยากเกินไปสำหรับคอมพิวเตอร์คลาสสิก แต่
ยังคงมีบทบาทในการพัฒนาอัลกอริทึม และ VQE ยังสอนให้เรารู้ว่าการถ่ายโอนขั้นตอนจากคลาสสิก
ไปควอนตัมไม่ได้ดีกว่าหรือแย่กว่าสำหรับทุกจุดประสงค์ แต่
มันเปลี่ยนปัจจัยที่กำหนดประสิทธิภาพของอัลกอริทึม นี่เป็นบทเรียนทั่วไปที่สำคัญใน
การคำนวณไฮบริดควอนตัม-คลาสสิก